I think coming out to Australia you've
got to realize that it's a much smaller
Market everyone knows everyone so you've
got to make sure you're on you know your
best behavior and you're you know
looking good your Brands good and that
you're creating relationships cuz in
Australia I think it can take a much
longer time to break into a client and
you know develop that relationship
whereas in the UK you know people are a
keen on a bit of spot business and then
you know I'm not going to take you call
for a year definitely the relationship
mentality out here is is is a lot lot
more longer term um and it takes a lot
longer to kind of uh break people down
and you know get get cozy with them you
know